Musik
Wir sind das, fucking Podcast-Dufu, immer noch besser als jeder Huse, So nahmere vorwärts und flausch ich dafür nicht so groß und schlauzig
K-K-K-K-Comedy, K-K-K-K-Comedy, besser als Böhm, man der ist gar kein Gott, das für mich!
Wir feiern unser Game, wir feiern unseren Fame! K-K-K-K-Comedy, K-K-K-Comedy, besser als Böhm, man der ist gar kein Gott.
Wir feiern unser Game, wir feiern unseren Fame, für ne Stunde scheiße labern, das ist doch insane.
U steht für UFO, O für Online-Tang, Florentin Ufo, P-P-P-Podcast, Ufo, Podcast, Podcast, Podcast, Podcast, Podcast, Podcast, Podcast, Podcast. Manchmal ernst, manchmal krass, aber Spaß, hauptsächlich Spaß. Geil. Hallo und herzlich willkommen zu dieser fantastischen neuen Ausfolge von Das Podcast Ufo. Hallo, herzlich willkommen. Eine neue Folge, heute am 1. Mai. Ah, die Feiertagsfolge. Vielen Dank an David G. für dieses fantastische Interview. Mega geiles Intro, vielen Dank. Wir kommen langsam in die Bredouille, dass die Intros besser werden als die Folge. Und sich selber kommentieren auch, also dass sie, das war jetzt ja schon Meta-Meta-Intro, Meta-Meta-Intro, also dass wir Zuschauer-Intros haben, ist ja schon so ein bisschen so ein Meta-Gag, dass die jetzt anfangen, selber zu kommentieren, finde ich jetzt auch nicht so schlecht. Ich finde es großartig, vielen Dank dafür, heute die erste Mai-Folge. Die große erste Mai-Folge. Wow, das ist ein Feiertag,
wie er im Buche steht.
Es gibt ja die legendäre,
die Simpsons erste Mai-Folge,
die Family Guy erste Mai-Folge.
Von der grossen Erste-Mai-Saga.
Gibt es da einen Film dazu, 1. Mai, warum das ein Feiertag ist?
Bestimmt gibt es da einen RTL-Dreiteiler
dazu. Bestimmt.
Die grossen Ersten-Mai-Kriege
oder sowas.
Wann kommt da mal wieder eigentlich ein RTL-D-Teiler? Ich habe dich jetzt falsch verstanden, RTL-3-Teiler, da dachte ich RTL-3. Warum gibt es eigentlich keine RTL-3? Das stimmt, man hat nach zwei gesagt. Es ist generell drei, ist eigentlich immer das Beste. Bayern 3 ist das Beste Bayern, Star Wars Episode 3 ist das Beste Star Wars Episode. Es ist eigentlich ist drei immer das Beste. Ja, ich glaube, man hat nach zwei gesagt, wir haben Monster geschaffen, jetzt ist es auch, komm jetzt. Das stimmt, jetzt kommt Super RTL. Ja, direkt Super RTL. Könnte man da, stimmt, nee, das hat ein New Magazin mal gemacht, dass die Sender alle Figuren sind und dann. Ja, if Sender were a guy. Ja, du. Alle Ideen wurdenbraten. Die Regel 34 ist ja Porn, es gibt Every Porn Exists, Everything That Exists Has Porn. Ich finde, es sollte einfach die Regel geben, Everything Exists. Das ist die Regel 35. Ich glaube, das ist Regel 1, Everything Exists. Wo sind die anderen und was sind die anderen Regeln? Regel Nummer zwei, Nothing Doesn't Exist. Was sind denn die anderen grossen Internetregeln? Ich glaube, das ist über Regel eins. Ja? Everything exists. Wo sind die anderen und was sind die anderen Regeln? Regel Nummer zwei, nothing doesn't exist. Was sind denn die anderen großen Internetregeln? Ich glaube, Regel sieben ist irgendwie so. Gifts sind nicht mehr lustig. Keep your links short. Keep your links short? Use bitly. Da haben sie sich die Regel gekauft. Dieser URL-Shortener. Niemand mag diese krassen Links. Einfach so, hey, guck, wir haben alle diesen einen Freund, der so, hey, guck dir mal dieses Katzengift an und dann so ein sechzehnzeiliger langer Link. Man denkt, um welche Umwege, durch wie viele afghanische Server führt mich dieser Link jetzt zu meinem Katzenziel? Es gibt auch, man muss sich so einen Graphen denken quasi. Qualität des Contents ist oben und rechts ist die Länge des Links. Und das muss im Verhältnis stehen. So, wenn die, und da gibt es eine Grenze, da gibt es eine Linie und die ist okay. Also sagen wir mal, die ist so eine 45 Grad nach oben lineare Linie. Wenn es abweicht, ist es weird. Wenn der Content zu gut ist und der Link zu kurz, ist es seltsam. Das merkt man, hat man ein schlechtes Gewissen. Man hat ein schlechtes Gewissen, weil man dachte, oh, der müsste aber jetzt... Auf der anderen Seite, viel schlimmer ist unten der Bereich, der unter der Linie dann, der 45 Grad Linie, weil da ist der Link zu lang und die Qualität zu schlecht und da denkt man auch Leute, ey und dann ist der Freund auch uncool, also wenn da durch 16 Zeilen kommt, mit drei Pixeln gross aufgerissenem Pferdemund, sagt man auch, ja. Ne, muss nicht sein, muss nicht sein. Tatsächlich war man bei einem, fand ich auch sehr lustig, bei einem Freund zu Gast über Silvester. Das erste Mal in meinem Leben war ich in seiner Wohnung und dann hat er so ein Kärtchen ausgeteilt mit dem WLAN-Passwort, damit alle WLAN-Passwort da mir ja wusste schon, dass die Gespräche nicht sonderlich interessant werden, da dachte er sich ich sorge vor, Plätzchen, Salzstangen und WLAN-Passwort und das WLAN-Passwort hatte 64 Stellen. Nein. 64 Stellen. Ach Gott, in so einem Haushalt. Ich weiß nicht. Das ist wirklich so dieses WLAN-Passwort und dann wirklich so ein ganzer Blogtext. Und ich glaube, ich habe es einfach dreimal falsch eingegeben und dann aufgegeben. Regel 36! Ja, Regel 36 ist auch, Leute, die 64-stellige Passwörter haben, sollten keine Silvesterfeiern veranstalten. Ja, auf keinen Fall. Weil das sind offensichtlich nicht Leute, die das machen sollten. Das sind keine partyerfahrenen Leute, These. Das sind Leute, die legen sehr viel Wert auf Internetsicherheit, IT wahrscheinlich, großes IT-Wissen auch da vorhanden. So Chaos Computer Club sind so Assoziationen, die mit mir reinballern, wo ich sage, dann feier keinen Silvester, geh, du kannst irgendwo hingehen. Es sind einfach diese krassen überzogenen Sicherheitsvorkehrungen, wo du denkst, okay, ich werde irgendwie auf Nein-Gag rumhängen und Wikipedia-Artikel nachschlagen, falls meine Freunde über ein Thema reden, von dem ich keine Ahnung habe und irgendwie brillieren will. Das ist es, Nein-Gag und Wikipedia, dafür brauchst du nicht 64-stellige Sicherheitscodierung, brauchst du einfach nicht. Hat der großeorentin Will, der mehrfach mit dem Krimmelpreis ausgezeichneten Humor, hat der einen lustigen WLAN-Namen? Hast du einen lustigen WPA2-Namen? Äh, nee. Tatsächlich nicht. Was hat denn das Comedy-Genie, der, ich sag, preisgekrönte Spaßvogel Florentin Will Wilf ein WLAN-Passwort. Das ist ja so, es gibt ja Momente für Comedy und Momente, wo Comedy keinen Platz hat. Und für mich waren Momente, in denen ich... Lass mich die Frage umformulieren. Was hat denn das Grosste? In den Momenten, in denen ich den Router aufgebaut habe, war es für mich nie ein Moment, wo ich jetzt Lust habe, abzulachen. Sondern da war es so, oh, bitte, bitte,ier, bitte funktionier. Ist das der richtige Code? Kein Comedy beim Routeraufbau. Bin ich jetzt, man muss da irgendwo anrufen und dann bin ich da drin und dann tippt man das ein und denkt mir, bitte, bitte funktionier. Und wenn es funktioniert, ist das Problem ja vergessen. Dann ist ja egal. Und dann hast du irgendwie in zwölf Jahren kommt mal ein Gast und er sagt, was ist dein Passwort? Ja, Fritzbox QE am Ende. Und deswegen, nee, tatsächlich kein Humor zu suchen, weil es ist eine Entscheidung, kein Gag währt so lange, dass man den als WLAN-Namen verwenden kann. Weil jeder Gag wird irgendwann alt und du musst wirklich sehr viel Vertrauen in dein Gag-Potential haben, dass du dich dazu entscheidest. Ich respektiere jeden, der irgendwie dann WLAN-Meyer-Landruth oder irgendwie sowas hat und dann denke ich mir, wow, Commitment. WLAN-B, wo man auch dann schon ein bisschen zu viel um die Ecke gedacht wurde.
Ja, wo man einfach sagt, okay, vielleicht ein paar Ecken zu viel. Respektiere ich, aber bin ich selber tatsächlich nicht mutig genug, mich da zu committen.
Nee, nee, ich war vorgestern stolz, da habe ich bei einem Kollegen, bei dem ich war und hier in Köln, wenn man sich dann mit W-Name verbinden will, ist man ja tatsächlich konfrontiert mit sehr vielen Namen, also sehr viele Gags auch. Du hast auf einen, das ist wie so ein Witzebuch, ein aufgeschlagenes Witzebuch, ehrlich gesagt, so ein, man will sich mit W-Name verbinden in Köln. Es ist ein Lachoverkill, man kommt eigentlich erstmal nicht mehr raus. Und ich war stolz, weil mit dem Autorenkollegen arbeite ich schon sehr lange zusammen und ich dachte mir, komm, dein Challenge ist jetzt, du erkennst den natürlichen lustigen Namen oder auch nicht, aber du erkennst seinen WLAN an deinen Namen und an der Ausschlagsstärke, weil es müsste ja drei Striche haben, weil ich direkt an dem stehe. Und ich habe es erkannt. Ja? Ich habe es erkannt. Es war das unterstrich Internet.
Oh, das finde ich auch.
Das Internet. Und ich wusste, es passt so zu seinem Humor, so ein subtiler, leichter Humor. Das ist tatsächlich ein bisschen abgefahren, weil das Passwort für mein WLAN ist, das Internet. Das solltest du hier nicht öffentlich sagen. Naja, da kommen Leute vorbei und klauen meine Bits und Beize, oder was? Ich stehe da vor dir rum und spiele Pokémon Go. Scheiße.
Oder wie alte Menschen sagen Pokémon Go.
Das ist, glaube ich, genau die Grenze.
Die zwei traurigen Pummelubs, die du bei mir fangen kannst, hat ja eh schon jeder.
Ich frage mich, das ist, glaube ich, wirklich eine Grenze.
Ab welchem Alter sagt man Pokémon?
Das ist, also meine älteren Generation sagt Pokémon.
Ja, ja.
Und ich glaube, das geht so bis, sagen wir mal, Ende 30 noch. Und dann ist ein Kader Cut und dann darunter sagen alle Pokémon. Aber man betont beide mal die erste Silbe, ne? Pokémon. Pokémon, Pokémon. Aber es ist ein anderes O. Kurzes O, langes O. Pokémon. Pokémon. Weil niemand weiß, wie man es richtig ausspricht. Man weiss es ja auch nicht deutsch, ne? es ist ja Pocket Monster. Eigentlich ist Pokémon gar nicht so falsch, eigentlich ist Pokémon ziemlich falsch. Wie Pocket, ja, Pokémon Pocket. Pocket Monster, Pokémon. Moment, sind wir auf der falschen Seite von dieser Diskussion? Ja, ja. Und ich will so einen Ü40-Podcast mal gerne hören, die sich darüber lustig machen, dass man Leute Pokémon sagen. Das Problem bei diesen WLAN-Gags ist, wann kommt der Gag an? Ich bin auch in eine WG eingezogen und dann so, wie heißt das WLAN? Und dann meine Mitwohnerin ganz trocken, Alice im WLAN. Und du halt völlig trocken, ah okay, ist das Alice im grossen W, W minus, okay, was ist das Passwort? So, das geht halt komplett unter einfach. Das ist nicht der Moment für Gags. Ja, vor allem, da musst du auch professionell genug sein als Deliverer, dann sofort, auch wenn die Stimmung gerade schlecht ist, es gerade Stress ist irgendwie, dass du trotzdem den Gag delivers wie ein alteingesassener Stand-up-Comedian, oder die Ärzte, die zum 80. Mal Westerland auf der Bühne spielen, du musst noch mal deliveren. Du kannst da nicht sagen, ja, Alice im WLAN. Nee, das geht nicht. Kein schlechter Titel eigentlich. Da kommt dann so ein bisschen durch, es war nicht ihre Idee, den so zu nennen. Sie war dagegen, sie war für WLAN Meierland. Sie war für WLAN Räti. Aber sie hat diese Diskussion leider verloren. Ja, es klingt ein bisschen durch. Und muss jetzt halt immer das durchdrehen. Oh, leicht genervt auch davon. Das ist auch bei Abimotti so. Also ich habe unser Abimotto, Abipotter, noch niemals so gesagt, als sei es lustig gemeint. Immer, was ist euer Abimotto? Ja, Abipotter. Dieses süße Abimotto, wo Scherze mit drin sind. Abipotter, wir verlassen die Kammer des Schreckens. Das habe ich noch nie wie ein Gag delivered. Das ist so niedlich, wirklich, es ist so verrückt,
weil man kommt auf die Schule, um Gymnasium und man denkt sich,
Abiturienten sind Götter und sind erwachsen und die fahren Autos und die haben Bart und dann deren Abimotto, Abipotter, wir verlassen die Kammer, einfach so niedlich, Unangreifbar. Aber ich habe das Gefühl gehabt, bei uns hat sich das auch geschifftet. Also ich war damals, als ich in die Fünf kam, hatte ich Respekt vor den grossen Menschen. Diese Türme, wenn man da zu spät zur Matte kommt in den ersten beiden Stunden, dann rennt man durch den Gang und dann weicht man diesen grossen, endartigen Wesen aus. Und die hatten Rucksäcke ohne Tiere drauf. Ja. What? Das geht? Ja, ja, und ohne Blinklichter und ohne diese Absorber und sowas. Und die hatten keine Helme. Diese Metallkolben, aus denen man getrunken hat. Das stimmt. Woraus trinken die? Kein Portemonnaie mehr um den Hals hängen. Wie bezahlen die? Ach Gott. Keine Warnweste? Was? Viele, viele Fragen, viele Fragen. Als wir dann die Abipotter-Jungs waren, da habe ich das Gefühl gehabt, wurden wir ein bisschen schief angeguckt von den unteren Klassen, als ob wir nicht mehr ganz ernst zu nehmen waren.
Ich habe mich nie gefühlt wie der End.
Du meinst, du warst der Bruch, ab deiner Generation waren die Oberstufe nicht mehr cool. Ja, genau, es hat sich so ein bisschen, also auf uns wurde herabgeguckt auf eine Art. Bei uns war irgendwie, also wir mussten erstmal lange eine einzige Person bei unserem Abikreis bekämpfen, die als Abistreich einen Amoklauf vortäuschen wollte, wo wir gesagt haben, keine gute Idee, wir sind immer noch coole Freaks und so, jung, aber das ist halt nicht so vielleicht. Und gerade so, du hast ja dann so den Kreis der Klassenclowns und Klassenclowns müssen ja dann eigentlich immer alle Ideen gut finden, alle Streichel. Es muss dann auch ein Klassenclown-Rat, Krisenrat geben. Klassenclown-Krisen-Rat. Ja, wo man die roten Nase mal absetzt und sagt, Freunde, das funktioniert nicht. Herzlich willkommen zum Klassenclown-Krisen-Kreis. Ja. Und da muss man wirklich überlegen, da wird die Perücken abgesetzt, da wird sie abgeschminkt und da wird mal Tacheles gesprochen. Agendaplatz 1, die fette Rita.
Ist sie noch lustig?
Ei, ei, ei.
Alles klar.
Oder ist sie so ein Ha, ha, ha, ha.
Wenn es sehr viele machen, dann klingt es wie ein Lachen.
Ja, Erdkundelehrer, Herr Peniskopf, lustig, ha, ha.
Frage.
Ja, Jojo?
Ist es noch lustig, in die Geschichtsbücher Brüste reinzumalen oder die Penisse von, sagen wir mal, David von Michelangelo, also ein sehr cleverer Clowns?
Ist es okay, die Penisse anzumalen?
Wer dafür ist, ha, ha, gut, ist noch lustig. Punkt vier. Abi-Streich-Amoklauf. Naja, ich dachte... Nee, mach mal du. Also die Idee kam mir abends am Schreibtisch, wo ich nach neuen Gags überlegt habe für unseren Kreis. Und ich dachte mir, das wäre vielleicht wahnsinnig lustig, wenn wir so tun, als würden wir, als wir in Amoklauf. Ich kann auch gerne die Sturmmaske tragen und so und würde dann, mein Vater hat ein paar Waffen, da würde ich eine von nehmen, würde die natürlich dann auch nicht entsichern, vielleicht doch entsichern, damit es authentisch ist, auch wirklich entsichern, auch wirklich mit Patronen drin und das dann ja durchziehen. Ja, also ich will einmal kurz sagen, also liebe Clowns, liebe Frechdachse, liebe Ulkbolde, ja, wir haben natürlich letztes Jahr gesagt, okay, gut, danke, das muss nicht sein, aber sehr gut, gutes Timing, trotzdem nervig, wir haben damals schon gesagt, klar, Streicher dürfen alles, darüber waren wir uns einig, ich möchte Keine Umfrage. Auf der anderen Seite möchte ich sagen, gehen wir hier nicht ein bisschen zu weit. Also wir haben damals, klar, sechste Klasse, Genickbruch bei der hässlichen Rita durch den angesägten Stuhl, da waren wir alle noch einig, ja, das ist lustig. Die Zirkelnadel im Hintern von Simon war lustig. Absolut ulkig, ja. Dass wir irgendwie Frau Griebenhalter erfolgreich vermitteln konnten, dass sie schwanger ist. Da lache ich, da zähle ich heute noch davon. Ja, da kann ich heute noch nicht an mich halten. Richtig. Da wird der Kopf rot vor Spaß. Auf der anderen Seite möchte ich hier wirklich mal sagen, ja, die aktuelle Lage ist sehr angespannt. Ist es wirklich eine gute Idee, das durchzuziehen? Ist es wirklich so lustig? Was genau ist der Gag? Also wenn du mir vielleicht erklären kannst, wo der Gag liegt, also wo dann am Ende geroffelt wird, könnte ich es vielleicht ein bisschen besser nachvollziehen. Der Gag liegt ja wie immer, ganz kurz Mojo, der Gag liegt ja tatsächlich dann auch in der Auflösung, wie wir alle wissen, Fiedlein, Punchline. Und die Punchline wäre ja dann, danke, wäre ja dann, das aufzulösen und im richtigen Moment vielleicht dann doch den Klassiker, die Peng-Fahne aus der AK-47 rausschnellen zu lassen, sich die Haube vom Kopf zu nehmen und zu sagen, nee, ich war es die ganze Zeit, Jojo der Clown, Klassenclown aus der neuen B war es die ganze Zeit über. Dann muss man ja auch vielleicht darüber nachdenken, dass man im Einzelfall darüber lachen könnte. Meine liebe Freunde, unsere Organisation steht seit jeher auf dünnen Beinen mit langen Schuhen. Dünnen Stelzen. Ich weiß nicht, ob diese... Dünnen Dosenstelzen. Ob wir hier unsere Legenden nicht beschmutzen mit einer solchen Farce. Unsere Gruppe könnte zerschlagen werden aufgrund dessen. Und ich weiß nicht, ob das wert ist. Abstimmung? Wer dagegen ist, ha? Wer dagegen ist, ha? Okay, hat nicht funktioniert. Wer dafür ist. Kleine Intrige von mir. Wer dafür ist, ha? Ha. Du? Ja, ich habe mal eine Idee. Jetzt bist du dagegen und dann ist es Pat, weil wir nur zu zweit sind oder was. Ja, ich bin dagegen. So, warum? Scheiße. Wir brauchen mindestens, habe ich dir in Zeit gesagt, mindestens drei Klassenclowns auf der Schule.
Was sind wir für eine Schule eigentlich?
Wollen wir mit den Frechdachsen fusionieren?
Mit den Ulknudeln?
Die sind aber so prolly.
Also wir haben es auf jeden Fall dann nicht gemacht,
letzten Endes, und da ist die Grossteilung der Gereichung.
Wir bräuchten so ein Geräusch, wie man aus so einem Flashback wiederkommt.
Es ist ja oft so ein bisschen das Problem, also das kennst du ja wahrscheinlich auch in kreativen Meetings und wenn man Ideen diskutiert, dass eigentlich mehr Zeit darin fließt, schlechte Ideen wegzudrücken, als gute Ideen zu fördern. Es gibt immer so, drei Leute sagen was und dann geht es darum, dass zwei Leute die Idee des einen so lange wegdrücken, bis man fünf Minuten vor Ende der sagt, ja stimmt, die Idee war schon scheiße, wenn der jetzt zwei Köpfe hat, klar, wir müssen halt immer zwei Schauspieler machen und CGI und dann die Zwiegespräche ist, okay, lassen wir es, so, wir haben jetzt noch fünf Minuten, wie soll der Charakter sonst sein? Und dann kommt eine gute Idee und alle sind auch dafür sofort. Ja, genau. Und dann so, keine Ahnung, innerlich zerrissen. Ja, alles klar, machen wir. Ciao. Auf gute Ideen, genau, wird nicht so viel Zeit verschwendet, das stimmt schon auch. Schlechte Ideen, aber das liegt dann auch an schlechten Kreativen, die dann zu lange festhalten an Dingen. Wenn sie merken, dass der Raum toxisch auf die Idee reagiert und alle sofort mit nichts anderem beschäftigen, als sie die Idee niederzumachen, runterzudrücken, auch in der höflichsten Art und Weise, ist es natürlich dann auch ein Zeichen für dich, vielleicht zu sagen, also you have to read the room. Richtig. Schritt eins ist immer so, ja, aber das ist super schwer umzusetzen. Also die Idee ist super so, klar, aber wo kriegen wir jetzt acht Pferde? Eigentlich ist Schritt eins ignorieren. Ja Ja? Tatsächlich. Aber nicht offensiv, sofort dagegen reinzustellen. Ne, andere Idee pitchen und erst mal sagen, also weglachen oder sowas. Ja, das ist ja oft, also habe ich die Erfahrung gemacht, so ein bisschen das Filmfights-Problem, dass je länger man gegen eine Sache diskutiert, desto mehr Raum nimmt diese Idee ein und desto größer wird diese Idee, auch wenn man dagegen argumentiert. Und am Ende kommt es dann so, angenommen es werden drei Ideen genannt und eine wird attackiert und ganz viele Gegenargumente gegen eine. Am Ende der Diskussion wirkt es so, als hätte es nur eine Idee gegeben, weil alles sich immer nur um diese eine Idee gedreht hat. Und dadurch sagt man dann, ist es nur noch, machen wir die Idee jetzt oder nicht? Und es ist gar nicht mehr, welche der drei Ideen machen wir, sondern nur noch, machen wir diese eine Idee oder nicht?
Und wenn das dann runtergemacht wird, dann gibt es keine Idee mehr.
Genau.
Dann müssen wir beide gefragt und müssen sagen, ja, jetzt sind wir dran.
Jetzt kommt unsere Zeit gekommen.
Und niemand will seine eigene Idee nochmal einbringen, dann bringt man die Idee des anderen ein.
Ja, ich fand es eigentlich ganz gut, was Lisa gesagt hat mit den Schlangen.
Du bist eigentlich auch schwach, also nach diesem hart gefochtenen Kampf bist du auch ermüdet. Ja. Und dann noch deine Idee, inbrünstig zu pitchen, ist auch einfach nicht mehr möglich. Ja. Och, ey, das ist ein Anjob. Das ist wirklich anstrengend. Oh, Zeitreise und so nochmal. Oh, ich war gestern, na, ist das für ein Spoiler?
Keine Ahnung. Ich war gestern im letzten
Avengers-Film.
Oh, sag nicht, wie er heißt.
Sag nicht, wie er heißt.
Ich will nicht gespoiert werden.
Das letzte Spiel. Sag nicht, wie er heißt.
Letztes Spiel. Endgame.
Schluss damit. Endgame.
Jetzt reicht es aber auch.
Jetzt ist eh schon alles egal.
Avengers aus die Maus. Ich habe jetzt eigentlich, ich hab noch nie in Avengers geguckt und hab jetzt die letzte Woche mal ein paar geguckt, einfach um da reinzukommen und so, weil ich das rein Popkorrektisch total interessant, aus einer Autorensicht interessant finde, wie man das jetzt zu Ende bringt und so. Und rein konzeptionell finde ich das alles spannend, mich nerven die Filme einfach grösstenteils total und ich finde das schlecht und man sollte es auch nicht wahnsinnig unterstützen, weil es auch irgendwie die Kunst zerstört oder das Kino zerstört. Aber es ist natürlich auch schon interessant zu sein, in der Zeit zu leben, wo das gerade passiert und das mal anzugucken und zu bewerten, finde ich auch interessant. Deswegen habe ich mir das jetzt mal vorgenommen, ein paar Filme geguckt und es ist schon wirklich beeindruckend. Also vor allem, ich glaube auch nicht, dass es in der Zeitgeschichte schon mal einen Film gab, wo derartig viele aktuell krass bekannte Stars mitmachen, die Stardichte. Also es ist ja fast alle berühmten Schauspieler der Welt machen in diesem Film ja mit. Das ist ja, ich glaube, es ist fast noch nie da gewesen einfach. Ich kann mir das das jedenfalls nicht vorstellen, dass es so einen Film gab, wo derart viele zeitgenössische Stars
mitgemacht haben. Glaube ich nicht. Also der Abspann
war wirklich, war crazy. Der Abspann
war die Hälfte des Films. Der war langweilig.
Der Film war langweilig, aber der Abspann,
holy shit, wie viele Stars.
Ne, ich fand das wirklich
beeindruckend. Also man muss diesen Film nicht,
also der, das ist keine Maßstäbe, kann, diese Filme können lustigerweise auch gar nicht gute Filme sein. Die haben ja auch den Anspruch, ja auch gar nicht ein Film zu sein, sondern einfach ein spannendes Spektakel in der Zeit, solange wir Filme lang sein dürfen. und der war halt auch sehr, sehr lang jetzt, aber du kannst ja dann auch die ganzen Storylines gar nicht mehr ich weiß aber mit mit tor und hulk und captain america und captain marvel und so weiter dann hast du ja so eine dichte an an figuren dass du gar keine story mehr erzählen kann es eigentlich keine normale ja da wird ja auch alles über bord geworfen was so dramaturgisches wissen und so ist ja nicht mehr anwendbar weil es soere gibt. Das fand ich jedenfalls sehr spannend. Und dafür ist der Film gut gelungen. Okay. Kleine Kritik. Ja, ich komme da, glaube ich, nicht mehr rein. Ich habe die alle nicht gesehen und ich hätte das Gefühl, dass das nicht so viel Spaß macht, wenn man nicht alle kennt. Und deswegen lasse ich es einfach von Anfang an. Ich habe mir tatsächlich, als es immer hieß, Endgame-Spoiler, hab ich mir einfach den Wikipedia-Artikel durchgelesen. Das war mein Erlebnis dieser jahrzehnteumfassenden unendlichen Saga, die noch in hundert Jahren gelobt wird. Ich hab den Wikipedia-Artikel durchgelesen. Schön Sans Serif auf Weiss habe ich mir das gelesen und dachte mir, ich raff keinen einzigen Satz. Aber visuell ehrlich gesagt hast du da auch jetzt nicht wirklich was verpasst. Ich meine, da bist du schon gut aufgehoben. Ich habe kurz überlegt, ob ich mir vorlesen lassen soll. Man kann ja sich einen Wikipedia-Artikel vorlesen. Und schön zurücklehnen. Einfach schön die Augen zu machen. Mit dem Pinacolada in der Hand auf die Terrasse und dann schön vorlesen lassen. Ja, aber wahnsinnig langer Artikel auch. Also wahnsinnig viel passiert. Es gibt ja teilweise Filme, wo die Handlung zwei Sätze ist. Irgendwie versuchen die Bank auszurauben, dann peng, peng, peng und dann schaffen sie es auch. Ciao, so und dann okay. Niemand korrigiert das, weil das einer von Millionen Filmen... Weil niemand den Film auch sehen will dann. Ja, genau. Aber nee, von daher habe ich jetzt nichts, viel zu sagen. So was bei mir und Lost, ich habe dachte, da komme ich nicht rein und da will ich, das ist so viel Zeit und wow und das ist eine tolle Serie, die Maßstäbe setzt. Ich habe auch den Wikipedia-Artikel durchgelesen von allen Staffeln und war am Ende gut unterhalten. Ja. Weil der war auch gut geschrieben. Also muss man ja auch sagen, die sind ja auch toll geschrieben manchmal. Eigentlich müssen den auch dieselben Leute schreiben, die auch die Serien schreiben, damit das angemessen ist. Ja, wie gesagt, dramaturgische Wikipedia-Artikel finde ich ja interessant. Glaubst du, es wird auch zu deiner Netflix-Serie, 31. Mai, auf Netflix wird es auch ... Da kam jetzt ein Trailer raus, ein Teaser. Ja? Ja. Schaut den euch an. Wo findet man denn? Auf netflix.com slash teaser slash howtosaledrugsonlinefast punkt mp4. Okay. Habt ihr euch doch für mp4 entschieden? Wir haben lange überlegt. Nicht für mp5? Moff oder mp4. Ich habe bis heute auch, das war ja, das macht man ja nur deswegen, diese Serie, um herauszufinden, wird am Ende eine mp4 Datei an Netflix geschickt? Ja, es ist am Ende so trivial, es ist am Ende einfach eine Datei. Ja, die ins Internet verschickt wird. Und irgendwo muss jemand auf Download klicken bei Netflix. Auch Endgame ist einfach eine Punkt-Mov-Datei. Ist im Endeffekt nur eine Punkt-Mov-Datei. Man wartet da jahrelang drauf und so viele Emotionen, und am Ende ist es halt einfach eine Datei von vielen. Doppelklick, ich meine im Kino Doppelklick.
Und die auch sagen,
nee, ist aber jetzt auch aufwendig, ja komm, mach mal.
Und dann einfach im Kino, ja, Doppelklick.
Nein, Doppelklick.
Und der Beamer muss auch angemacht werden,
wie bei jedem anderen Film auch.
Und der Mauszeiger muss noch so an Rand gefahren werden,
damit die Leute im Kino sich nicht
beschweren. Vollbild!
Und dann muss noch Curs ein Bild. Top offen. Jetzt schreibt Melina schon wieder. Ja genau. Ja wann kommst du denn heute Abend nach Hause? Muskus und Slack. Ich würde gerne mal ein Kino aufmachen, ehrlich gesagt. Ja? Ja. Ja, weil in Kamen damals, in meiner Heimatstadt, gab es kein Kino. Und ich fand das immer sehr schlimm und schade. Deswegen ist mein großes Ziel, so viel Geld zu verdienen, dass man im Kino, dass man ein Kino in Kamen öffnet. Und dass du deiner Heimatstadt auch was zurückgibst. Sie hat dich hervorgebracht, sie hat dich unterstützt ihr Leben lang. Nein, hat sie nicht. Und dass du auch was zurückgibst. Eigentlich hat sie nicht viel für mich getan. Kam wollte mich verhindern. Kam hat versucht, dich kleinzuhalten. Kam hat versucht, mich kleinzuhalten. Und jetzt bin ich hier in Köln. Ja, ich würde wirklich knallharte, wer redet, fliegt raus, Politik umsetzen. Wirklich, also wirklich so zwei Leute mit so einer Superstalker engagieren, die einfach jeder, der auch nur ein einziges Wort sagt, sofort abspritzt, direkt. Aber auch mit sowas, schon direkt mit Sionkali oder halt irgendeiner weirden Chemie. Ja, so ein bisschen, ja, das ist so ein bisschen nach Zitrone. So ein bisschen, dass man sich denkt, ah, nee, das ist schon, dass es brennt oder so leicht ätzt. Ja, aber ich will ja auch dann nicht die Schmerzschreie haben. Ich will ja eher sowas beruhigen, das ist eher so Baldrian. Ah, okay. So Kamille oder so. Nicht, dass man einschlägt. Chloroform. Ja, genau, dass man einfach so ein bisschen lockerer, einfach ein bisschen relaxed. In Endgame ist auch jemand, mit dem ich da drin war, der ein riesen Marvel-Fan ist. Deswegen habe ich das auch noch mit eigentlich gemacht, alles die ganze Odyssee auf mich genommen. Und der ist eingeschlafen. Wirklich, ja. Und am Ende habe ich so auch noch mit eigentlich gemacht alles die ganze Odyssee auf mich genommen und der ist eigentlich wirklich ja und am Ende habe ich so gefragt, ich musste sehr lachen zwischendurch, aber du warst du aber auch weg und dann gesagt ja schon so gute 20 Minuten einfach mal weg, aber bei diesem Film war es auch egal, der ist halt 5 Stunden lang, der ist auch immer egal, dass man zwischendurch war, 20 Minuten verpasst. Die Spannung ist einfach zu groß, man kann das nicht ertragen. Ich kam auch zu spät rein, weil keine Werbung war. Es war keine Werbung. Wer soll denn damit rechnen? Also wenn man sagt, der Film fängt um 21 Uhr an, fängt der doch eigentlich erst um 21.15 Uhr an, das weiß doch jeder. Ja, der fing Punkt 21 Uhr an. Das kann man ja nicht wissen. Das war ein großes Problem. Und dann dieses Geducke, dann muss man vor der Leinwand herlaufen, muss sich ducken und man weiß genau, es bringt auch nichts, wenn ich mich jetzt duckke. Komm, ich renne, es ist eh unangenehm. Das ist wie bei Reden, wo man nicht weiß, wenn man schnell ist oder nicht, macht das einen Unterschied. Das hat aber mal Galileo getestet. Ja, mitbass das auch getestet. Ich weiß nicht, was das Ergebnis war. Und wenn die zu unterschiedlichen Ergebnissen gekommen wären, wären wir auch doof. Aber stell dir vor, du bist der größte Marvel--Fan, seit Jahrzehnten wartest du auf den großen Abschluss, hast alle Comics nochmal gelesen, alle Filme nochmal gelesen und dann sitzt du hinter Stefan Thielsel. Der zu spät kommt erst, was habe ich verpasst? Und er dann an unsinnigen Stimmen lacht. Wo ist Reihe F? Ah, unten. Wer ist das? Das ist der Hulk. Hä? Ich dachte, der ist grün. Nicht immer. Na, halt ... Hä? Ah, unten. Wer ist das? Das ist der Hulk. Hä? Ich dachte, er ist grün. Nicht immer. Hä? Wo ist Spider-Man? Warum spielt Mark Ruffalo sich selbst? Warum sind es die Avengers und Mark Ruffalo? Hä, war der nicht klein? Der war gerade noch gross. Der war doch mal klein. Wen meinst du? Der kleine Blaue. Paul Rudd war doch gerade noch groß. Sonic, die Schlümpfe. Hä? Das ist ja kein Spoiler, aber am Ende gibt es halt diese Riesenschlacht, wo natürlich alle Superhelden gegen die ganzen Bösen kämpfen. Und ohne Scheiß, wie geil es gefunden hätte, wenn einfach so ein Tor aufgeht, Doctor Strange macht so ein Portal und Batman kommt raus und Superman kommt raus. Batman, Marge Simpson macht so ein Paket. Und Super Mario und dann denkt man auch, geil. Garfield. Aber das finde ich wirklich mal ganz geil. Also gut, zumindest mal Batman und man sagt am Ende, die ganzen DC und Marvel hätten verbündet Kämpfen gegen die Bösewichte. Das wäre schon krass. Das wäre am Ende einfach so, wirklich dann irgendwie Walter White. Wobei, ich habe echt gedacht gestern, das ist ja die Finalschlacht. Ja, wie gesagt, das ist ja kein Spoiler, wenn man sagt, die ganzen Superhelden kämpfen jetzt dagegen. Ich sehe die Kommentare schon. Dann stell dich mal vor, wenn jemand so eine Zeitreise macht in den 50er Jahren, ein Mensch aus den 50er Jahren, ich meine, was die für ein Tempo gewohnt sind und für Storys und dann stell dir mal vor, du setzt den in Endgame und du siehst diesen kleinen Raccoon durchflitzen, dann diesen blauen Alien-Menschen, dann jemanden, der riesig ist, grün ist, jemanden, der ganz klein ist, Leute mit Antennen, Leute ohne Antennen, fliegende Dinge, eine Walküre, das ist einfach weird und das ist einfach ein riesen Clusterfuck und Und stell dir mal vor, du setzt so jemanden und der denkt einfach, die Welt ist am Abgrund. Aber gibt's jede Farbe einmal? Weil Hulk ist ja grün und ich dachte immer so, wie ist das, die müssen wir ein Problem sein, wenn jetzt ein neuer Superhead kommt, der auch grün ist. Und dann Hulk so, ja wie, wir nehmen jetzt ein Grün in unsere Tru auf, oder was? Green Lantern. Kann der eine blaue Jacke tragen
zumindest, oder irgendwie sowas? Weil irgendwann
kann man die ja nicht mehr auseinanderhalten. Green Lantern
ist Grün, aber auch DC.
Green Arrow.
Weißt du nur Arrow? Ich hab keine Ahnung.
Ich weiß auch nicht genau. Ich hab wirklich keine Ahnung.
Und Jerry Miranda hat mich ganz verwirrt,
weil der spielt ja in beiden, bei DC
und bei Marvel, jeweils den Normalo mit dem Bogen. Der eine ist Hawkeye, der andere ist Arrow.
Der kommt da nicht mehr raus. Und er wurde nicht als Robin Hood gecastet. Das ist eigentlich der große Skandal. Was soll das denn eigentlich? Er ist der Normale mit dem Bogen.
Ja.
Und der von Arrival.
Ja, gut, wenn er am Ende auch einfach den Bogen raus und aufs Alien-Schiff schiesst und es explodiert.
Fuck it.
Ja.
Er schiesst sie erst mal, er schießt die Aliens, er schießt den Chinesen einfach so, was ist da passiert? Ich bin Jeremy Renner, ich spiel den mit dem Bogen. Dann schießt du die Kamera auf. Ich schießt die Kamera um, bleibt überliegen und der Rest ist einfach, wie er der Crew erklärt, hey, was, nee, nicht mit dem
Bogen wegnehmen, ich bin der mit dem Bogen.
Pew, pew, pew, pew,
Renner!
Und dann Abspann, aber gekippt,
weil die Kamera auch gekippt ist, ist der Abspann
auch vertikal. Ja, finde ich gut, aus dem
Typecast kommst du auch nicht mehr raus, einfach.
Genau wie die ganzen Game of Thrones-Leute,
jetzt ist ja die letzte Staffel Game of Thrones-Läuten.
Ach ja, wir müssen auch darüber reden. Und das ist ja auch so ein bisschen so ein, ja, die versuchen hier und da mal andere Filme zu machen und so, aber ich glaube, die ganzen Game of Thrones Leute, jetzt ist ja die letzte Staffel Game of Thrones läuft. Ach ja, müssen wir auch darüber reden. Und das ist ja auch so ein bisschen so ein, ja, die versuchen hier und da mal andere Filme zu machen und so, aber ich glaube, das wird nix. Nee. Ich glaube, das wird nix. Nee, man hat es so festgefahren. Ich glaube, die sind alle verbrannt. Ja, genau wie Rupert Weasley, wie hieß denn, Rupert Grint. Rupert Grind. Aber der will doch gar nicht weitermachen. Nee. Ich glaube nicht. Watson. Das sind ja auch alles keine guten Schauspieler, auch bei Game of Thrones die ganzen Kinder. Du weißt ja bei Kindern nicht so, du nimmst das Kind, das halt nicht ständig heult. Wo endet es? Du hast zehn Kinder zur Auswahl und neun davon heulen ständig. Und dann nimmst du halt die andere, diese zehnte. Und die spielt dann halt Arya. Ja, natürlich ist sie keine gute Schauspielerin. Und jetzt dann irgendwann ist sie super alt und ist super reich und jeder kennt sie. sie und dann so, ja, einen anderen Film. Ach so, die ist gar keine gute Schauspielerin. Ja, Mark Hamill ist auch kein guter Schauspieler. Nee. Nee. Fast niemand, der im Film zu sehen ist, ist ein guter Schauspieler. Muss man auch mal sagen. Vielleicht. Jeremy Renner. Jeremy Renner. So, der ist, das ist ein, der kann verschiedene. Ist ein solider Schauspieler. Der schießt nach oben, der schießt nach unten. Der schießt nach vorn, der guckt böse, dann werden die Augen zu Schlitzen. Ja, der sammelt die Pfeile vom Boden auf, das kann er gut, der kann es einfach. Das fehlt übrigens immer, sowohl bei Legolas, als auch bei Robin Hood, als auch bei Arrow, als auch bei Hawkeye, dass die Szenen, die After-Credit-Szene, wie die alle Pfeile wieder einsammeln müssen. Legolas, wie heißt das hinten, der Köcher, ist immer voll. Immer voll. Und auch so direkt nach der Schlacht, wo sie sagen, oh, wir rennen jetzt Marion Pippen hinterher und Legolas so, gibt ihr mir die... Ganz kurz. Sorry, wenn wir alle zusammensuchen, geht's schneller. Wenn jeder Kurz umkreist von fünf Metern nach Pfeilen sucht... Guckt kurz, sind die mit den goldenen grünen Federn oben. Ich hab meine Handynummer draufgeschrieben. Oben mit dem, wo Legolas steht.
Ist das eine Schlange?
Das legt die, legt sie, legt sie hin.
Legt den Ast wieder weg.
Das ist ein Ast.
Nee, wenn ihr oben guckt, da wo die Federn sind, da ist so ein Name Tag.
Legolas Meierling Bruchtal 2.
Ja.
Einfach oben gucken.
Genau.
Ist das ein Fall?
Nein, das ist ein Arm. Ach, okay. Freunde, ich mache's selber. Ich mach's selber. Ich komm nach. Ich bin nicht der Schnellste, Freunde. Lassen wir's... Lass mich zurück. Und dann alle so, nein, wir lassen dich nicht zurück. Ja, dann hält... Gut, wir drehen uns im Kreis. Puh, Leute, ey, das wird eine anstrengende Reise. Die Extended-Scenes sind echt interessant.
Und dann im Baum steckt der und dann kriegst du den auch nicht mehr raus.
Da ist doch die Axt von hier, Gimli.
Einfach ein Segen dagegen.
Du musst einfach rein, machst du Axt rein, machst du Axt raus.
Ja, aber der wirft auch manchmal den kleinen Äxte.
Und dann töten die hundert Eurokale und dann musst du den einsuchen, wo du die Axt reingeworfen hast.
Ja, du bräuchst so eine Fernbedienung, dass es so aufblinkt. Ja, irgendwie sowas. Weil so Geräusche macht. Da, da hinten. Da ist sie. Ja, das ist schwierig. Aber das sind so Szenen, die ich mir wünschen würde. Ja. Es gibt keine gute Herr der Ringe-Parodie. Also dieses Synchro von Coldmirror, aber jetzt wirklich selber gedreht? Nee, ich meine, selber gedreht wie Spaceballs. Ich weiß nicht, aber diese Parodien, irgendwie sind Parodien, es gibt halt nur so diese Date-Movie oder Scary-Movie, die sind halt alle grottenschlecht, aber gute Parodien, glaube ich, sind selten geworden, sind rare geworden. Ich finde nicht, also wenn man sich anguckt, zum Beispiel American Vandal, die True Crime. Ja, das stimmt. Ja klar, so Richtung Mockumentary, so dann Dokumentar schon. Aber wirklich, wo man sagt, so das ist jetzt die Verarschung von Game of Thrones.
Ja gut, Superhelden manchmal hier schon so da, Deadpool und jetzt Shazam, aber das sind ja keine Parodien, das sind halt dann andere Superhelden.
Ja, und vor allem, die kommentieren sich auch immer selber, diese Filme, die sind da so selbstironisch schon. Das sind Marvel-Filme, die kannst du ja nicht parodieren. Die nehmen sich ja zu wenig ernst dafür. Ich fand, er ist Into the Spider-Wars. Ja. Fand ich sehr gut. Hast du ihn gesehen mittlerweile? Endlich! Ja, ich hab ihn echt gesehen. Und? Fantastisch. Unglaublich. Unglaublich guter Film. Also wirklich eine ganz tolle Geschichte. Ja. Tolle Botschaft auch da drin. Sieht super aus. Unfassbar gut. Also unfassbar gut, da ärgere ich mich, wenn ich den im Kino gesehen habe, weil der wirklich einfach fantastisch aussah. Also wo man sagt, das ist einfach eine tolle Idee und auch toll geschrieben und da wird nicht alles gestimmt. Und ja, wie gesagt, die Spider-Man-Filme sind einfach, bin ich großer Fan von, Spider-Man Homecoming war auch super und kommen jetzt auch bald neue raus mit Jake Krill in Haar. Ja, die schaue ich mir auch gerne an irgendwie, weil die sind irgendwie...
Die sind lustig, da kann man lachen, da sitze ich da und lache mich tot. Aber innovativ fällt mir gerade ein, wir haben eine Einsendung bekommen von einem Fan, von einem Hörer, man weiss ja nicht, ob die das gerne hören, man weiss nur, dass sie den Podcast hören, und zwar zum Thema FC Köln Toaster. Wir haben tatsächlich die vielleicht einzige Person der Welt gefunden, die einen solchen Toaster hat.
FC Köln Toaster tostet den Kölner Dom und spielt die FC Köln Toaster. Wir haben tatsächlich die vielleicht einzige Person der Welt gefunden, die einen solchen Toaster hat. FC Köln Toaster tostet den Kölner Dom und spielt die FC Köln Hymne, wenn der Toast fertig ist. Ich habe von Borussia Dortmund auch eine Einsiedlung bekommen. Ach cool. Und er hat geschrieben FC Köln Toaster Ich liebe ihn, aber meine Freundin hasst ihn. Ja, das war doch Borussia Dortmund. Ach, der war Borussia Dortmund? Ach, ich habe das Bild gar nicht gesehen. Ich habe nur, ich dachte, das ist FC Köln.
Das Bild wächst ja gar nicht mehr an.
Das lädt immer nicht so schön.
Bei mir laden die Bilder immer nicht. Aber finde ich
großartig und ich kann mir das sehr, sehr gut vorstellen,
wie die Freundin ihn hasst.
Und das sind wirklich so diese,
wirklich so eine Freundin, die dann irgendwie so dieses BVB-Logo
in der Mitte, so einen Kreis
verbrannt, alles außenrum roh
und dann so, fuck it. Das sind echt über deinen Toaster reden. Das sind auch Beziehungen, das macht Beziehungen auch stark, das Aushalten, sowas Aushalten. Ja, die völlig unnötigen Probleme Aushalten. Die man ohne den Partner gar nicht hätte, Aushalten. Aber lustig, ich fand toll, wie der Stand, also das Foto war, es war ein tolles Foto. Ich hätte mir das Foto angucken sollen, ich bereue es jetzt wirklich, dass ich das Foto nicht gesehen habe. Man findet es auch leider nicht weiter. Scheiße. Dafür dann doch zu oft. Es ist in der Waren als Internets verschwunden. Oh Mann. Es war toll, wie er da stand, dass man sich so viel Mühe gibt. Das klingt jetzt blöd, weil er musste nur eingesteckt werden und hingestellt werden. Ja. Aber dass man das macht für diesen Gag-Toaster. Ich fand das irgendwie liebevoll. Ich fand das total süss, dass jemand hat sich diesen Toaster dahingestellt.
Das Erste, was ich mache, wenn ich zu Hause bin, ich schaue dieses Bild an, wirklich.
Ich kann es dir auch jetzt kurz raussuchen.
Aber ganz kurz, wo wir gerade eh schon in der Community-Feedback-Kurse sind.
Wir haben eine Einsendung bekommen, und zwar was ganz was Feines, weil Stefan Tietze hat ja mal wieder versucht, das physikalische Universum zu verstehen, und er hat die uralte Frage gestellt, wie ist das eigentlich mit dem Rückspiegel im Auto? Ja. So, kannst du noch mal kurz seine Verwirrung erklären? Nee, nee, ich merke nicht, dass du das so ammoderiert hast. Nee, es war eine, die spannende Frage, die ich aufgestellt habe, die ich mir beantwortet habe, war nämlich, braucht man eine Brille, wenn man in den Rückspiegel schaut und alles in der Entfernung scharf sehen will, weil du guckst ja im Endeffekt auf etwas, was nur sehr kurz, also was sagen wir mal 50 cm von dir entfernt ist oder 30. Alles, das müsstest du ja scharf sehen und das fand ich mal interessant. Oder muss man auch eine Brille aufsetzen, um das, wenn man kurzsichtig ist, in der Ferne scharf zu sehen. Oder kann man dem Spiegel eine Brille geben? Oder kann man dem Spiegel eine Brille geben? So, und da haben wir jetzt eine Einsendung bekommen, und zwar von Ben, der schickt uns einen Clip. Und zwar hat er anscheinend mit dem besten Optiker Deutschlands gesprochen und der gibt folgende Antwort. Egal, welche Fehlsichtigkeit jetzt den Mangel ausmacht, dass man in der Ferne schlecht sieht.
Ob das jetzt weitsichtig oder kurzsichtig ist, beides ist möglich, sieht man in der Ferne schlecht, so ist der Spiegel im Auto nur eine Umleitung. Das heisst, man könnte sich genauso gut rumdrehen im Auto und nach hinten schauen, man hätte dieselbe Qualität, als ob es durch den Spiegel sozusagen noch mal umgeleitet wird. Man gewinnt vielleicht 50 cm, was die Distanz zum Spiegel ausmacht, zum Objekt. Aber die Schärfe, die schlechte Qualität bleibt dieselbe der Spiegel, der ja im endlichen Bereich 50 cm vor einem ist, der kann durchaus im schärfen Bereich der Fehlsichtigkeit noch sein. Nehmen wir mal an, wahrscheinlich ist es eine Kurzsichtigkeit, zwei Dioptrien, Kehrwert 50 cm, von da an alles, was weiter weg ist, auch nach Spiegelumlenkung, wird unscharf. Ich hoffe, ich habe euch damit geholfen. Bis dann, tschüss. Ja, vielen Dank an unseren neuen Optiker-Experten. Ich würde sagen, den nehmen wir auf in unser Team, unser Expertenteam. Wir haben jetzt einen Optiker. Mir gefällt auch einfach das Dreh dich einfach um. Dieses Passiv, also das war ja eine, muss man sagen, nett verpacktes Dreh dich einfach um. So ganz verstanden habe ich es noch nicht, ehrlich gesagt. Es ist ja eine Umleitung, das habe ich jetzt mitgenommen. Also du siehst es trotzdem unscharf, weil es ist nur eine Umleitung der tatsächlichen Entfernung. Es ist ja genauso, wie wenn du dich umdrehen würdest und dann siehst du ja auch nicht scharf in der Ferne Ferne. Ja, es ist ja quasi Licht, Spiegel leiten das Licht ja nur weiter, die Wellenlängen. Jetzt kommen wir näher. So, da kommen wir näher, glaube ich. Und deswegen geht es im Endeffekt, es ist trotzdem nicht so einfach zu verstehen, weil alles, was in dem Bereich ist vor dir, kannst du ja sehr scharf sehen. Und das Spiegel ist ja im Endeffekt, das Licht wirft ja allesamt auf den Spiegel, das ganze Bild. Ja. Ich frage mich aber, ob man Spiegel kreieren kann, wo das möglich sein könnte vielleicht. Aber was ist der Unterschied dann zwischen dem Fernseher zum Beispiel? Also wo ja auch Sachen im Hintergrund sind. Ja. Aber gut, da ist es ja nicht, da ist ja keine wirkliche Tiefe, sondern. Ja, oder ein Fotoapparat, lustigerweise ja. Wenn ich mein Handy, wenn ich die Frontkamera aktiviere, sehe ich dich ja jetzt scharf, auch ohne Brille. Das ist ja spannend. Ich bin jetzt quasi von Florentin abgewandt, habe meine Frontkamera angeschlossen, so, und habe mein Handy jetzt und kann ihn angucken. Ich kann sogar auf Florentin zoomen. Das heißt, du könntest eigentlich deine Brille komplett ersetzen,
dadurch, dass du ständig durch deine Kamera guckst.
Ja, genau.
Ich kann theoretisch die ganze Zeit so durch die Welt laufen und zoomen und Leute anzoomen.
Da denken zwar alle, weil das so ein Creep, der Fotos von einem macht.
Aber.
Ja, also das ist ja, finde ich ja spannend.
Vielleicht gibt es ja auch Spiegelballen bei der Wand.
Aber du kannst ja nicht ein Foto angucken und den Hintergrund scharf stellen mit deinen eigenen Augen, weil der ist ja so, wie er ist. Obwohl, im Spiegel kannst du ja in den Spiegel gucken und dann dich entscheiden, möchte ich das, was vorne im Spiegel ist oder was weit weg im Spiegel ist, fokussieren. Und dann macht es schon einen Unterschied. Ja, weil es eine Umleitung ist und kein Abbildnis. Ich finde es nach wie vor nicht so einfach zu verstehen. Und ich fand es ein bisschen unbefriedigend, die Antwort, ehrlich gesagt.
Lieber Optiker, falls du zuhörst, wir brauchen nochmal eine doppelt so lange Erklärung. Es ist der alte Krieg der Wissenschaft. Was ist los mit Spiegeln? Schlaue Leute müssen halt auch einfach erklären können. Das ist sehr wichtig, um uns nicht abzuhängen. Ja, das ist das Problem. Für Experten sind Sachen ja so selbstverständlich, dass man sie gar nicht erklären muss. Und jeder Mensch, der sie nicht versteht, ja einfach unglaublich gut ist. Eben, und dann schmeißt er mit Begriffen um sich, wie Umleitung. Ja, oder Dioptrie. Was? Was zum Teufel? Promille? Ich weiß gar nicht mehr, was hier los ist. Und dann ist es auch schwierig. Ich fand das lustig. Er hat mir mittlerweile übrigens auch die Sachbücher gekauft von Rekam. Ah ja, die pinken. Die sind wirklich fantastisch. Und da habe ich auch Quantentheorie, ist mega. Und bei Quantentheorie finde ich sehr lustig, am Anfang ist viel über die Geschichte. Eigentlich ist die erste Hälfte die Geschichte von Quantentheorie. Und was ja auch Sinn macht, das Pferd von hinten aufzuholen. Und dann kommt ja lustigerweise ein König vor. Ich weiß ja noch, wie heißt der noch mal, ich weiß gar nicht mehr, der hat jedenfalls mehrmals in der Geschichte gesagt, so, dann wissen wir ja jetzt alles, dann fokussieren wir uns auf die richtigen Dinge im Leben. Der hat so ein paar Leuten einfach mal gesagt, nee, da machen wir es nicht, das reicht ja. Und er hat einfach manchmal beschlossen, dass die Menschheit jetzt alles weiss. Wie cool war das, einfach der Trottel der Geschichte, der einfach ab und zu die Arroganz besessen hat, zu sagen, nee, gut, dann haben wir es ja jetzt raus. Genau. Und er hat ja auch neue Leute nicht mehr daran forschen lassen, an Quanten und so weiter, weil er gesagt hat, nee, das war es jetzt. Wir haben es ja jetzt rausgefunden. Und er hat dann jegliche Forschung blockiert auf dem Feld. Fantastisch. Ja, das stellt so ein bisschen das Konzept König in Frage, an dem ich eigentlich immer sehr gehangen habe. Aber es ist vielleicht keine gute Idee, jemanden, dass eine einzelne Person das entscheidend zu lassen. Vielleicht nicht, ja. Aber es ist interessant, ja auch berühmterweise Max Planck, dem man gesagt hat, ja, lass das mal mit Physik, wir wissen ja alles. Und der dann ganz fantastisch ist mit dem Ausbekommen. Lord Kelvin war das. Lord Kelvin? Lord Kelvin. Geil. Aber ein guter Name für die Wissenschaft.
Lord Kelvin hat gesagt, nee, nee, nee, wir wissen es. Aber das finde ich ganz gut. Ich mag es auch sehr, diese Bücher in der U-Bahn zu lesen, ehrlich gesagt. Ah, wenn man sehr klug wirkt. Oh, das ist Quantentheorie in der U-Bahn zu lesen. Generell, Reklamlesen ist schon mal, oh, und dann noch die Lilanen, wo alle sich denken, oh, oh, oh. Und dann guckt man mal hin und dann sagt man Relativitätstheorie, wow. Wow.
Aber auf der anderen Seite denkt man sich ...
Umleitungen ...
Auf der anderen Seite trägt man sich ...
Optiker sein. Und dann guckt man mal hin und dann sagt man, Relativitätstheorie, wow.
Aber auf der anderen Seite denkt man sich, er weiß es ja noch nicht. Wohingegen ein Physiker, der alles weiß, liest nichts. Und dann denkt man sich, oh, der liest nichts, aber der weiß es ja schon. Wohingegen du, wie bind ich mir die Schuhe, wow, der liest das gerade. Mit zugegriffenen Augen und so grünselter Stirn.
Und so ein Kopfschutzlieger. Und die ganze Zeit immer zwischen diese eine Mit zugegriffenen Augen und so grunzelter Stirn. Und so Kopfschutz
und die ganze Zeit immer zwischen diese eine
Seite in der Hand hat und die so umdreht.
Ja, ja. Weil er immer, weil er offensichtlich
diese Stelle stolpert, die genau im Seitenumbruch
stattfindet. Und siehst du da.
Ja, und der so einen Finger auch hinten hat und immer
hinten nachguckt. Im Glossar. Im Jahreszeiten,
im Register. Genau, ich habe
das Bild gefunden vom Toaster. Oh, danke,
das ist ja ein Service. Oh, guck dir mal den an. Mensch, das ist ein schöner Toaster. Pralles Toastergerät. Schwarz und gelb, wie die BVB-Bienchen sein müssen. Nennen die sich die Bienen? Tatsächlich ist das Maskottchen die Biene Emma. Der BVB ist übrigens schwarz-gelb wegen Bier und Kohle. Zwei Dinge, die die Stadt Dortmund ja auch irgendwie geprägt haben. Wow. Mensch, was du alles weißt. Du bist ein richtiger Dortmund-Experte. Ich komme ja von da weg. Ja, was man mir immer gesagt hat bei Bayern, die bayerische Flagge ist ja blau-weiss, wegen dem Himmel, weil der blau-weiss ist in Bayern. Ja gut, ich mir, ja gut, der Himmel ist ... Müssten dann nicht alle Flaggen blau-weiss sein? Himmel ist halt überall blau-weiss. Anders als in Norwegen vielleicht, wo er manchmal grün ist. Also das hat mich immer nicht ganz überzeugt, ehrlich gesagt. Aber wie damals Bayern so, wir brauchen eine Flagge, wir brauchen eine Flagge, wir brauchen eine Flagge. Ist blau-weiss noch frei, Himmel? Ja, ich gucke mal kurz nach im Buch. Ja, die haben hier so ein Schwein, ein Eber. Ja, ist noch frei. Nehmen wir das doch. Ha, zack, Feierabend!
Schwein und Eber. Ja. Da hat man sich einfach festgelegt. Ich würde, ja, Flaggen sind weird, ne? Ich frage mich, wann die nochmal geändert werden, weil zum Beispiel, ich finde es ein bisschen peinlich, dass Deutschland als einziges Land Gold hat. Ich finde das ein bisschen peinlich. Peinlich.
Und auch alle gehen darüber hinweg, so, ja die haben Gold, aber ...
Ja, weil man stellt sich da und natürlich ist es kein echtes Gold. hat. Ich finde das ein bisschen peinlich. Und auch alle gehen darüber hinweg, so, ja, die haben Gold, aber ...
Ja, man stellt es nicht dar, und natürlich ist es kein echtes Gold, aber kann nicht einfach mal irgendwie einfach sagen, Freunde, Volksbegehren, gelb, oder?
Immer gelb.
Schwarz, rot, gelb.
Ist denn Belgien auch Gold?
Nee, die sind alle gelb. Deutschland ist das einzige mit Gold,
die überhaupt Gold haben. Das ist genau
wie wenn du sagst, die Schweiz hat Weiss und Purpur.
Sagen wir mal Rot.
Nee, Purpur. Nee, die Schweiz hat ja vor allem
auch ein Quadrat.
Ja, das stimmt. Das ist auch seltsam.
Und Lettland hat ja gesagt,
nee, wir finden die Flagge von Österreich schick,
wir nehmen ein bisschen dunkles Rot.
Wir nehmen so Bordeaux.
Fuck you, Lettland, ey. Lettland kotzt mich so an. Lettland kann weg, ohne Witz. Ja? Ja, Lettland kann weg. Eher als Estland? Ja, ja, ja. Ich weiß noch mal, Estland. Nee, aber Lettland kann, also da können wir wirklich einfach mal einmarschieren und sagen, Leute, hör mal auf. Hör mal auf. Leg die Waffen runter. Das ist auch mal, also, ihr hattet jetzt echt lange genug Spaß.
Was ist Let?
Weißt du, ich verstehe Island. Ja, Island. Okay, got it. Finnland, die Finn. Frankreich, das Reich der Franken. Got it, ja. Lett? Was soll das sein, Lett? Nee, nee, nee, sag mal, sag mal jetzt gerade, was ist denn? Ja, es war damals, war catchy.
Hä, wie? Wie Letten sind wir halt. Wir sind die Letten. Wir sind die Letten. Dann haben wir uns überlegt, wie können wir das nennen, Lettenland, das klang irgendwie. Warum seid ihr denn Letten? Ihr seid doch Letten, weil ihr in Lettenland seid. Wir kommen aus dem grossen, weiten Letten. Hä? In den Berg. Der Berg heißt Lett. Der heißt Lett und wir sind die Letten am Lett. Scheiße, der heißt halt nicht Lett. Aber was soll das sein Lett? Was ist denn Deutsch? Was ist denn Deutsch? Na, Deutsch, wir Deutschen. Ja, wir sind die Letten. Das ist keine Sitz. Das Spiel können wir zu Ende spielen. Ja, okay. Gut. Okay, fahr die Panzer wieder heim. Sorry, war ein Fehler. Lett ist, okay let is fat. Können wir das machen? Let is fat? Neuseeland, Neufundland, das sind Namen. Ja, Grönland. Das ist wirklich so. Grönland. Ja, wegen Grün. Grün. Ne, Grün. Das ist Grün. Ach, Grün. Komm, ey. Siehst du schon. Das ist doch... Ja, das ist kompliziert. Es gibt ja so diesen großen Raum, wo die Vertreter von allen Ländern sind. Und... Raum. Oder Uno oder so. Ja, Zimmer. Nennst du Kammer. So, ja. Ich würde wirklich bei jeder Rede sagen, so, jetzt kommt meine Rede, kann Lettland mal raus? Lettland-Estland mal raus für die Rede? Die nehmen Plätze weg. Die nehmen den grönen Plätze weg. Haut ihr mal ab! Nee, Grönland ist ja auch Dänemark. Man fliegt immer über Grönland, wenn man in die USA fliegt. Ja, und es ist nicht mehr im Ansatz grün. Es ist das schwarz und weisseste Land, das ich je gesehen habe. Ich frage mich immer, warum man nicht einfach über den Atlantik fliegt. Ist es schneller über Land oder ist es sicherer? Wie Auftrieb. Das Meer ist ja kalt. Du willst doch nicht mehr steigen, aber auf einem gewissen Punkt reicht es doch. Aber du musst ja weniger... Ich glaube nicht. Je schneller man fliegt, desto mehr Auftrieb hat man. Aber man kann ja auch nach unten lenken.
These, je schneller man fliegt, desto höher fliegt man auch. Nein.
Doch, klar. Nein.
Natürlich! So funktioniert doch ein Start.
Ja, desto mehr Auftrieb hast du natürlich auch. Aber du kannst ja dagegen lenken und so.
Ja, du kannst ja die Flügel ändern. Aber das heißt, wenn du jetzt Aufwind hast, dann kannst du schneller fliegen? Nee, bei Aufwind hast du Auftrieb ohne Motorleistung. Aber Motorleistung ist ja Geschwindigkeit. Du kannst ja nur schneller und langsamer fliegen, dein Motor. Ja, was ist die Frage? Hilft es dir als Pilot, wenn du über Auftriebzonen fliegst? Was
genau hilft das? Ich glaube nicht. Ich glaube, das einzige, was hilft, ist Rückenwind, weil dann
bist du schneller, trotz geringerer Motorleistung oder bist einfach schneller am Ziel bei gleicher
Motorleistung, weil du fliegst. Bei Gegenwind bist du deutlich langsamer am Ziel. Aber musst du nicht vielleicht ein bisschen nach oben steuern, wenn du normal fliegst, dass du nicht abstürzt? Nee, eigentlich nicht. Die Idee ist ja, man steuert gerade. Die fliegen genau so schnell, dass sie die Höhe behalten. Kein Kommentar. Das sind diese Fragen, wenn ich jetzt früher, weißt du, vor 20 Folgen habe ich hier noch selbstbewusst darauf mit einer falschen Antwort geantwortet, das traue ich mich nicht mehr. Ich habe mich gerade so klug gefühlt, weil ich dachte, ah ja, klar, die fliegen über Land, weil Land ist wärmer als Wasser und warme Luft steigt ja nach oben, das heißt, wenn du über Land fliegst, hast du Aufluft, Auftrieb, wohingegen über dem kalten Wasser nicht. Aber jetzt kriege ich nicht zusammen, warum das ein Vorteil sein soll, Aufluft zu haben. Ich glaube, das ist einfach nervig, weil du die ganze Zeit gegenlenken musst. Irgendwann sagst du auch, ich fliege jetzt mal über Wasser. Aber du kannst ja Ballast abwerfen. Wir haben die Reiseflugur erreicht, wir fliegen jetzt mal über Wasser. Ich habe mal ein Praktikum im Deutschen Museum in der Segelflugabteilung gemacht. Ja, du bist auch nicht müde, das zu erwähnt. Und der hat gesagt, wenn du im Segelflugzeug bist, flieg über Felder. Also Agrarfelder. Ja, ein Segelflug hat aber auch keinen eigenen Antrieb. Der muss ja mit Aufwinden leben. Das ist ja deren und Winden generell. Der hat gesagt, flieg nicht übers Meer. Hat er gesagt? Ja. Wenn du in, wenn du in Deutschland startest, ist es nicht so leicht, ans Meer zu kommen. Warum hat er überhaupt so emotional auf dich eingeredet, wenn du eh nie in einen Flieger gestiegen bist? Oder warst du kurz davor mal in so einem Flieger? War es ein Museum oder ein Fliegerflugplatz? Dessen Idee war, er will, dass mehr junge Leute Segelflugzeug fliegen. Ja. Und dafür braucht er mich, damit ich alles, was man zum Segelfliegen braucht, wie macht man den Führerschein, wie kommt man an sein eigenes Flugzeug, damit ich das aufarbeite. Diese beiden Dinge, weil das war es dann auch, ja. Ja, wie ist das mit dem Flugrecht, darf ich überall starten, wie hoch darf ich fliegen, so diese ganzen Sachen. So hoch wie du kommst. Ah ja. Das ist bei Segelfliegen auch so. Ja, versuch mal. Dürf ich denn 10.000 Meter? Ja, versuch doch mal. Okay, du kannst es nicht drüber lustig machen, aber es ist durchaus ein komplexes Thema, das Facetten hat, die ich alle durchtrunkte habe. Und dann sollte ich das aufarbeiten. Und ich habe schon versucht, ihm so ein bisschen durch die Blume zu sagen, hast du schon mal von World of Warcraft gehört? Junge Leute haben nicht so viel Lust auf Segelflug, aber in letzter Zeit denke ich mir immer häufiger, soll ich es nicht machen? Ich hatte Lust auf so ein handfestes Hobby. Ich habe nur so Hobbys, so dieses, ah, dann spielt man halt ein Videospiel oder so. Aber ich hätte Lust auf ein handfestes Hobby, so Angeln oder Segelflug oder irgendwas, wo man sagt so, weil ich habe ja letztens, wir haben ja über Free Solo gesprochen. und so klettern. Das ist ist schon ein cooles Hobby, weil du kommst rum, du kommst irgendwo hin, du sagst erst der kleine Berg, dann der mittelgrosse Berg, dann der grosse Berg. Reisen ist auch ja schon nicht so schlecht. Ja, aber Reisen, das ist so, da bist du nicht gefordert, da gibt es keine Herausforderung beim Reisen. Du fährst halt zum Taj Mahal, guckst den an. Es kommt auch an, es kommt auch an, wie du reist und wie viel du vorher planst. Das ist auch schon mal eine Herausforderung.
Auf der anderen Seite gebe ich dir aber recht, ein handfestes Hobby ist schön, auch angeln, finde ich super interessant.
Also irgendwas mit Natur, weil das ist ja was, was wir gar nicht haben, also in unserem Leben, Natur oder sowas.
Und das finde ich nicht so schlecht. Ich finde auch, Segelfliegen ist natürlich auch toll,
wenn wir in einem Segelflugplatz hin kamen und sehr viele Leute waren da immer.
Ich war auch jedes Wochenende quasi, ich habe da Leuten beim Segelfliegen zugeguckt. Du hast immer nur zugeguckt? Mein Hobby war Eisessen am Seelflugplatz. Du hast jedes Wochenende denen zugeguckt und hast es nie selber gemacht? Ja. Und bei dir kam nie der Wunsch auf, es auch mal selber zu machen? Nö, nö, die ist auch im Fliegen. Ich hätte gerne Kratzeis. Ich hätte gerne Bum-Bum. Bum-Bum oder meistens Kaleepo-Cola, stehe ich am Rand, habe geguckt und dann kam, und dann habe ich, ich wusste auch dann schon viel. Und wie sind die gestartet, mit so einer Motorspule oder mit? Motorspule oder mit einem anderen Propellerflugzeug. Dann gezogen? Ja, wurden gezogen. Und dann sind die gestartet und dann auch wieder gelandet. Und dann guckt man hinzu mit der Sonnenbrille und dann blinzelt man, weil die Sonne zu hell ist. Du hattest eine Jugend, ey. Dann wendet man sich wieder dem Calipocola zu. Da muss man ja auch dann auch ab und zu mal sich um das Calipocola kümmern, sonst ist es ja geschmolzen. Und dann kommt schon wieder das Neue. Beisst du denn beim Calipocola durch das Papier? Auf gar keinen Fall. Nee, du beisstt so generell. Nee, keine Kohle wird gelutscht. Aber es gibt ja das Lutschen und es gibt das gierige Lutschen. Das gierige Lutschen ist ja das Saugen, dass du saugst und dann saugst du ja das Gute aus dem Eis raus und hast dann nur noch diesen traurigen Eisblock übrig, der weg muss. Das hast du nie gemacht. Nee, nee.
Eigentlich ist es ja Lecken. Es darf kein Eiswürfel überbleiben.
So ein geschmackloser Eiswürfel.
Aber Lutschen ist doch Lecken plus Saugen.
Ja.
Oder? Weil Lecken ist ja einfach nur Lecken.
Wohingegen Lutschen ist ja schon die Saugkomponente,
also die Unterdruck im Mund.
Ja, ich sag mal, Lutschen ist Lecken 2.0.
Also so eins mehr, eins mehr Lecken. Aber wo ist die Saugkomponente beim Lutschen? Ist schon auch vorhanden, oder? Na, das Schlöfen, jetzt sind wir beim Schlöfen. Jetzt verwirrst du dich noch mehr. Aber das ist immer so die große Gefahr bei solchen Eis, dass man zu sehr dran saugt und dann alles raussaugt und dann hast du nur noch dieses... Ja, und dann ziehst du den Farbstoff raus und dann merkst du schon, ist ja gar nichts mehr drin, dann kannst du es wegdonnern. Das waren dann auch keine schönen Tage, manchmal war das auch nicht schön. Aber wie es bei jedem Hobby ist, man gewöhnt sich dann dran. Ich hab das immer sehr genossen, den Fliegen in Zukunft. Ja, aber das war ... und das ist ein schönes Hobby. Ich hab jetzt überlegt, einen Motorboot-Führerschein zu machen, entweder oder ... Flugschein. Wo willst du denn hier ein Motorboot fahren? Im Rhein oder was? Ja, du kannst am Rhein einen Motorboot-Führerschein auch machen. Hier in Köln. Ein kleines Bötchen kaufen und vom Rhein kannst du ja überall hin. Kleines Motorbötchen kaufen? Ja. Wie viel verdient man mit einer Netflix-Serie, dass du jetzt über ein Motorboot nachdenkst? So ein kleines Bötchen. Sag nicht Bötchen! Da müssen ja jetzt nicht zwei Whirlpools drauf sein, das reicht ja einer. Da muss man ja auch jetzt nicht jährig werden oder sowas. Also ein schönes Bötchen damit nach Cannes fahren. Aber warum denn dann nicht segeln? Ist das nicht mehr eine Herausforderung zu segeln? Ja, deswegen nicht. Da kommt dann Wind und dann nicht Wind und dann kannst du jetzt nur gen Süden fahren und dann bleibst du auch erst mal im Süden für acht Jahre. Ja, das war früher so, ne? Die Römer hatten so eine riesige Flotte und dann so, oh, jetzt nehmen wir aber mal Karthago ein, ja, Wind ist nach Süden. Ja, dann halt das. Ja, dann erstmal. Guck mal, was da kommt. Guck mal, was da passiert. Afrika halt. Ja, haben wir aber das größte Teil schon eingenommen. Ha, ihr seid schon da? Ja. Seid ihr Römer? Jo. Ah, fuck. Aber wir kommen jetzt hier nicht mehr auf. Ich weiß nicht mehr, was ja heißt. Ich habe das Latinum, ich weiß nicht mehr, was ja heißt. Si claro? Si? Nee, oder? Was war denn nochmal ja auf Latein? Bin ich bescheuert? Ich habe das fünf Jahre in der Schule gehabt, ich habe das Latinum und ich weiß nicht mehr, was ja heißt. Ja, aber so wenn du halt Katul übersetzt, da kommt auch nicht ja und nein vor. Bei Latein hast du ja nie dieses
Where is the tourist information bureau, sondern du hast immer irgendwie Cäsar, ja habe ich die
Geile hier abgeschlachtet und er sagt nie ja. Ich hätte gerne eine Kutsche nach Palermo, bitte.
Bitte im Rauch, nicht im Raucherabteil. Entschuldigen Sie, wo finde ich die Agora? Ubi est Agora. Pardon? In der Bibliothek bitte nicht sprechen. Silentium en la bibliothecum. Ja, das stimmt, das ist nicht anwendbar, weil es nie auf, ich habe meine Hausaufgaben nicht, auf wie kriege ich ein Eis, wie teuer ist das und das, wie viele Gulden sind ein Taler. Ja, dieses Dialogtraining, Sprachen lernt man denn, normale andere Sprachen über dieses Dialogtraining, in Latein gar nicht. In Latein ist es nur vage Kriegsschauplätze. Wie es Cäsar, Cäsar ad flumen est, aus.
Cäsar ad flumen est, Cäsar zang.
Ist ad flumen est. Aus. Cäsar ad flumen est? Cäsar ist krank. Cäsar ist krank. Ach so, ich schätze Cäsar ist krank. Cäsar hat eine Erkältung. Cäsar hat sich erkältet. Cäsar flu est. Schon eine lebendige Sprache auf eine Art, aber halt auch mause mause tot, auf eine ganz andere Art. Die ist wirklich sowas von weg vom Fenster. Ich weiß auch echt nicht, was ja heißt. Aber das ist mir jetzt echt unangenehm. Kann man bestimmt hundert Leute schreiben. Stefan schaut lieber nach, damit uns niemand schreiben muss. Kann man einem das aberkennen dann? Quoque? Itaest. Itaest heißt ja? Itaest. Ite, stimmt, Ite. Oder? Ne, nein, nein, was ich dir gerade gesagt habe.
Ja, aber Ita ist, das ist ja ein Verb offensichtlich mit ist.
Die haben einfach kein Wort für ja, die sagen, das ist so.
So ist es.
Also ja.
Ja.
Oder Certe, sicher.
Certe.
Oder Vero.
Und was heißt nein?
Diese Kopfabgeste.
Nihil. Nichts.
Die sagen, das ist wahr oder sicherlich oder so ist es oder nichts.
Kommst du heute Abend zur Party? Nichts. Nichts.
Nein, also gar kein...
Na ja, Serte, sicherlich.
Ja, das ist eine schöne Sprache auf jeden Fall.
Ja, pos est.
Nächste Woche sind wir in München, in Minga, deiner Heimatstadt.
Oh, sehr was grischtig, so, endlich unsere Live-Tour-Gedreite.
Aber wenn du einmal hier rum Münchners, dann kann sich in die Herzen der Münchner schnabbeln.
Das kann ich ja dann nicht.
Wir freuen uns natürlich auf alle, die kommen. Leipzig ist ja ausgefallen, das heißt, wir hatten jetzt lange keine Live-Show, aber die nächste kommt in der kommenden Woche in München. Dann zeige ich dir mal ein bisschen rum, englischer Garten, schön Monopterus, ja, schöner Schäden, Spirle und Schnüt oder sowas. Birle und nicht Schnüt? Schnüt? Ich war schon mal in München und mir hat es sehr gut gefallen. Wir können ja gerne in die Pinakothek gehen, das war toll. Ja, schön, Brandhorst. Brandhorst. Ich habe schon von der Zelt. Ja, sehr gut, machen wir. Jep. Gut. Wir begrüssen euch alle nächste Woche, alle, die kommen können. Ansonsten haut rein, macht's gut, noch eine schöne Woche. Eine schöne Woche. Vielen Dank nochmal an David G für das fantastische Intro. Das war wirklich fantastisch. Haut rein, macht's gut. Und schickt uns gerne weiter Intros. Vielen, vielen Dank. Macht's gut. Ciao.